episode three of the rings of power has
just dropped and with it a ton of new
questions theories and connections to
the lord of the rings from who this
mysterious adar is galadriel's discovery
of numenor and hal brand's mysterious
past i will be saving all my trailer and
book spoilers until the end of the video
and don't worry i'll give you a warning
before we get there so hitch a ride on
the high seas let's get into it we pick
up with our elven watchwarden erendir
who we last saw captured beneath the
tunnels of the southland's town of
jordan he and the human healer bronwyn
noticed that although the town was
destroyed there were suspiciously no
bodies as we'll find out they've all
been taken as prisoners to construct
this elaborate tunnel network a network
that has even made its way over to theo
in bronwyn's town of tierrarad that's
why they had to evacuate at the end of
episode 2. you'll notice the orcs here
literally burn in sunlight having to
keep themselves covered by the sun with
bone helmets and clothing not only do
the tunnels allow them the ability to
move about undetected but they also keep
them out of the light when orcs were
first created by morgoth there was no
light in middle earth so when the sun
first arose it was a complete shock to
their systems and thus they were driven
underground but as erendier later
surmises there is a third reason for
these tunnels the orcs are searching for
something something he believes could be
a weapon perhaps this is the blade theo
found which bore the mark of sauron a
blade which magically reforged itself
after consuming part of his blood in my
episode 2 video i theorized this may be
the magical black blade girthing an
infamous sword which had broken in half
and was said to possess supernatural
powers captured alongside erendir are
several of his fellow watch wardens
chiefly his superior revvien and partner
maydor they'll soon devise a plan to
alert their kind and stamp out this evil
once and for all across the sundering
seas galadriel finds herself aboard a
numenorean ship she and a mysterious man
named hal brand were but two survivors
of both a serpent attack and violent
tempest numenor is the westernmost of
all the mortal realms an island kingdom
that was given to their people as a gift
from the elves for their help in the war
against morgoth leading this ship is
ellendil who you may remember from the
fellowship of the ring as the man who
was brutally smashed by sauron in the
war of the last alliance the war which
saw his son isildur cut off sauron's
fingers and defeat the dark lord
illendil is curious what strange omen
would bring an elf on his ship his name
does mean elfriend in eldar and his
ancestors remained loyal to the will of
the valar the spirits who shaped and
ruled the world but lately numenor has
been increasingly isolationist turning
away even the elves with whom they once
shared trade technology and other
customs in the show this hasn't really
been explained however later in the
episode we do get a clue the queen
regent muriel tells her father the
exiled king that the time they have
feared has come the elf has arrived so
it seems some sort of prophecy is at
play here one which foretold of
galadriel's arrival hence why the
numenoreans shut themselves out from
their kingdom how can an elf arrive if
they are never allowed to come in the
first place it's also interesting to
note that it looks as though the queen
is looking down at the king as if he's
on a bed perhaps he's gravely ill
galadriel sees that ellen dill has taken
her brother's dagger the physical
reminder of the oath she swore to track
down and defeat sauron but she knows
this is not the time nor place to
attempt its retrieval numenor is both
stunning and massive between its
waterways are huge visages carved into
the mountainside it reminds me of that
scene in the fellowship of the ring
where the fellowship rides past the
gates of argonaut where you see these
two huge monuments in the jackson films
these are carvings of ellendile and
izeldor halbran notes that numenor is
not like the lands he came from that's
because these men are not like his own
kin who chose a blood oath with morgoth
instead of aligning with the elves the
numenoreans prospered while the people
of the southlands lived under the
watchful eye of the elves their power
kept in check as we walk through the
streets of numenor toward the palace
there are a few interesting things one
the townspeople seem awfully distrustful
of galadriel there having been no elves
in the land for decades second is
halbran's peaked interest in the
blacksmith we'll later see him attempt
to get a job there where he states that
no other man knows this craft better
than him i wonder if they'll ever team
up with kelebrimbor and elronto in
episode 2 we're devising a way to build
a forge stronger than the world has ever
seen galadriel and halbrand are brought
before queen regent muriel who seems to
have taken over rule of numenor from a
king who is locked away in the tower in
the books this king's name is tar
palantir palantir translating from
elvish to farsighted and considering
we'll find out that this king foresaw an
elf arriving i think it's fair to say
he's living up to his name palantir is
also the name of the seeing stone used
by saruman these stones could be used to
communicate with one another and to see
many things across the face of the world
a palantir was used by sauron to
eventually ensnare saramon so it could
be assumed that if the king has access
to one of these he may have been given
one as a gift by sauron in disguise as a
way to slowly corrupt the numenorean
people who at the time would be one of
his greatest threats in lot lore
ellendale will bring seven of these
palantiri from numenor to middle earth
with one of them eventually falling into
the hands of saruman during the third
age in numenor no one kneels which i
thought was pretty interesting as
galadriel introduces herself the crowd
is quite shocked they would know who
galadriel is and she would have been
quite renowned she is not one to mince
words and her abrasive manner in
addressing the queen almost gets her
arrested all she wants is a ship to
bring her back to middle earth but it's
hal brown who intervenes asking the
queen to allow her time to convene with
her counsel to think about galadriel's
proposition before they make their
decision to the queen's side is
chancellor r farazon he doesn't get much
screen time but in the books he's the
queen's cousin he is wary of the
newcomers telling the queen that they
better take care of them quickly for an
avalanche can start with but one stone
the queen grants galadriel and hal brand
their three days so long as they don't
cause any trouble or leave the palace
grounds of course the two wastes no time
completely disobeying these orders while
hal bran wants to enjoy his time here
believing numenor a paradise ripe for
opportunity galadriel doesn't want to
waste any time halbrin reminds her she
needs to seek peace if she is to heal
this hatred in her heart something that
was echoed by elrond in episode 1. he
gives her her dagger back something he
swiped off ellendill while hugging him
on his way out surrounding the shores of
numenor is ellen deal's son isildur he's
training to become a member of the
seaguard a position held in high esteem
amongst the numenoreans but isildur
isn't too focused on the job instead
something whispers his name from afar
his friends later remarked that he's had
his head in the clouds this is a very
important time for these men for in nine
days they will embark on their sea
trials a four-year journey to make
officer joining them ashore is isildur's
sister aryan who's a character created
for the show in the books elendil only
has two children isildur and his brother
anarian as we see a white tree outside
the palace in numenor the queen remarks
the faithful believe something bad is a
foot when its petals fall that each
petal is a tear from the spirits of the
world the valar who pass judgment over
them the very seeds from this tree will
eventually be taken to middle earth
where they will sprout the white tree we
see at ministerith in return of the king
she asked ellendilde if he believes in
the white tree but he brushes it off
stating he doesn't believe much
importance ellen dill has broken
precedent by saving the elf and bringing
her back but since the elf came to her
from the sea and their saying is the sea
is always right he believed it the
prudent thing to do muriel knows
ellendill's name means elfren so it's a
very calculated move that she gives him
a promotion and the task of looking
after galadriel if galadriel's arrival
is something she's worried about why put
her under the care of someone who could
potentially be sympathetic to her cause
maybe she is testing his loyalty after
all she tasks him to quote perform a
service and then gives him a sword in my
spoiler section i'll delve a bit more
into her motivation here as there is an
image which really starts to paint a
picture of what exactly is happening in
numenor ellendale's name also has
another meaning in endoneic the common
language of numenor it means one who
loves stars an apt name if you're a sea
captain who needs to use the stars to
navigate stars and constellations are
something the stranger is obsessed with
so i wonder if there's any connection
there there's also this sword i'll leave
it up to you if you think this sword is
the one that will eventually cut off the
ring of power from sauron a sword called
narcio it looks markedly different than
the one portrayed in peter jackson's
versions all we know of narcio is that
it will eventually come to the hands of
ellendale toward the end of the second
age back in the southlands which we
theorized last episode will become
mordor we learn that the orcs follow a
leader named adar a strange name
considering it's elvish sauron did have
many names back in the day so it's
possible adar is him or one of his
minions take with this what you will but
the elvish translation of adar is father
the orcs demand that the large tree
blocking the tunnel's path should be
felled but revien makes a stand saying
it would be faster to go around it this
proves to be in defiance of this orc
slaver who slashes madore's throat
resulting in aaron deer proclaiming he
will tear the tree down this allows him
to see above the tree line an area which
looks to be rotting away in episode 1
the tavern keeper did warn of rumors of
a farmer's crops being eaten away by
poison erendier does say something to
the tree unfortunately i don't speak
elvish but i imagine it's an apology for
what he's about to do galadriel makes
her escape on route to steal a boat when
she's stopped by elendil she's surprised
that he can speak elvish he was raised
by many who speak it in fact it's still
taught at their hall of law suddenly
galadriel's interest is piqued he agrees
to take her there this does of course
mean she will leave the palace grounds
but it's never clarified if she's
allowed to do so under the supervision
of illendil who was tasked to look after
her meanwhile halbrin tries to get a job
at the blacksmith even though he may be
skilled no one can forge steel on
numenor without a guild crest he'll end
up stealing a crest from one of the
locals who doesn't take too kindly to it
being pilfered there's quite a bit of
mystery surrounding hal brand he
single-handedly takes down all four of
these men he's great at pickpocketing
and claims to be a master smithy later
in the episode galadriel will visit hal
brand in jail at the hall of law she
found the same symbol he bears on his
pouch it was the sigil that united the
scattered tribes of the southlands
galadriel surmises that halbrand is the
king of these people but habran says
he's heir to more than just nobility but
to the ancestors who swore a blood oath
to morgoth this is part of the pain that
he lives with the sins of the father so
to speak but for galadriel their meeting
was more than just chance something
greater is at work and the two of them
must venture to middle-earth to redeem
their bloodlines the only problem both
of them are stuck here and she has no
army something she says is about to
change the hall of laws is packed with
ancient scrolls a tower built by elros
himself elros was the twin brother of
elrond and he chose to live as a mortal
man becoming the first king of numenor
galadriel would have known him hundreds
of years ago my interpretation of this
painting here is elrus is on the left
with his brother elrond to the right the
only reason the hall of laws wasn't torn
down was because of the last king for
the king was loyal to the elves and
still is something that got him exiled
to the tower of extreme concern is a
report written by a human spy showing
that same mark of sauron we saw on the
forge and theo's sword it's not a sigil
at all rather a map of the southlands
where the enemy's dungeon was located
the inscription on the note is written
in the black speech the speech created
by sauron during the dark years for the
servants of mordor it tells of the
creation of a realm where evil will
endure and thrive this realm is in the
southlands and the plan is to be enacted
by morgoth's successor upon morgoth's
death it's this revelation that further
proves to galadriel that sauron is out
there what i find more concerning is
that this note seems to have been
overlooked by the numenoreans if i were
a king and heard of the return of the
dark lord that's something i'd
definitely want to investigate not have
this super important letter collecting
dust at a hall that was almost destroyed
perhaps this is related to why the king
is exiled and maybe those who have taken
over him are corrupted by sauron's power
in middle earth we're back with the har
foots who have begun their harvest
festival which marks the kickoff of
their great migration largo brandyfoot
is still recovering from his injured leg
but if they don't come up with some way
he can travel they run the risk of being
left behind it is harfoot tradition that
those who can't make the trek are left
behind their names instilled in the book
of the left behind nori is preoccupied
with what we saw the stranger do last
episode control a bunch of fireflies who
made the formation of a constellation if
there's anything that can help them
figure out what's going on it's probably
in saddak burrow's book we saw this book
in episode 1 and how it predicted the
antlered travelers and these two wolves
beside it an event if this book is
prophetic we'll likely see in the
episodes to come using her friend a
poppy as a diversion nori grabs a piece
of the book which has the same
constellation the stranger mapped out
unfortunately for nori and the
brandyfoots the stranger gets a hold of
this paper and accidentally burns it in
the fire causing a commotion and the
discovery that nori has been hiding this
stranger in their midst the harfots
being a superstitious and on guard
people find this of the utmost danger
nori's actions are so grave that it
could even result in her being
decaravaned although she makes an
impassioned speech that friends are
needed to survive and that the stranger
was meant to meet with them sadak and
the harfoots are not having it nori will
not be the caravan however her family's
cart will be put at the back of the pack
her mother says this is basically the
same as having their names stamped in
the book of the left behind since with
their father's injury there will be no
way they can keep up the stranger
watches on from afar and i couldn't help
but think that he's starting to
understand back in numenor ellendill's
children question him about galadriel
isildur wants to escort her back to
middle-earth but his sea trials are in
nine days something his father will
order him to do izaldor doesn't want to
become a member of the seaguard he longs
for something more maybe somewhere it's
hinted that his brother anarian ventured
off to without the approval of their
father illendil will go on to say there
is nothing for their people on the
western shores of middle earth the past
is dead i found this a bit odd what kind
of past do they have there for all we
know ellendill and his family have been
on numenor their entire lives was there
some sort of falling out with the
brother which led him off there
ellendill goes on to note that the
watery path heals all wounds so maybe
the brother died i don't think that's
the case because it would be a huge
departure from the books so maybe it's
something else entirely regardless the
fact that all three of his children have
been talking behind his back it can't
make him feel all that good what good
news does come however is in the form of
ayarian's acceptance into the builder's
guild something which never would have
happened if it weren't for her brother's
insistence that she reapply with the
caravan on its way that brandy foots
fall behind they won't be able to make
it in their father's condition luckily
they have this stranger and if you stick
around for my spoiler section you'll see
if he uses some sweet magic or just
pushes the card anyway he ends up
calling nori and her family his friend
aaron dear and the captives make their
escape using the sunlight to their
advantage to slow down the onslaught of
orcs we also get our first look at a
warg who to me at least looks different
than the beasts which stalk the harfoots
in episode 1. revien manages to make it
over the trench but is shot it seems
even the area surrounding the trenches
are infested with orcs making escape all
the more difficult aarendir is captured
and told to be brought forward to adar
they really tease us by not showing us
his face but from what we can see he
does look elvish that long hair and
v-shaped face he doesn't look like an
orc to me here's a better picture of him
from the promotional material and he's
played by joseph maul who some of you
may remember played benjen stark in game
of thrones but just exactly who he is
and why he's commanding the orcs remains
to be seen now here is your book and
trailer spoiler warning where we take a
look at both of these to find out where
this season might be headed i won't be
going over every single clip just the
ones that kind of pertain to the new
info we received this episode it looks
like galadriel will get her ship we're
here in numenor and she's even got some
sweet new armor i think it's safe to say
that she's off to middle earth in this
shot galadriel shakes hands with hal
brand we'll see him in the same armor
later on fighting on horseback here we
have ellendil at the docks but take note
of all the white petals falling around
him these are most likely the petals
falling from the tree we saw from up
above we'll later see galadriel watch
these petals blowing violently in the
wind looks like the stranger has himself
surrounded by three of these beasts
hinted at in episode 1 and prophesized
in saddakburu's books in the back you
can make out nori and if you look really
close there's one other person here
which we can see in this other shot is
poppy the stranger will later use some
sort of slam wind attack to fight the
beasts off i like this sort of ominous
image of chancellor r farazan watching
the queen give a speech in the books he
usurps her and takes her as his wife
culminating in a chain of events which
will lead to numenor's downfall here's
galadriel with hallbrand in that sweet
new armor and galadriel tells him
whatever he did in the past to be free
of it here's a better shot of king
during the third with his son prince
during the fourth in the background the
last we left them they were planning a
deal with elrond and the elves of oregon
a number of orcs follow theo through the
forest maybe their evacuation caravan
gets attacked or theo gets separated
we'll later see him in a human town
hassled by this old man who asked him if
he's heard of sauron theo is inspecting
his arm here but we're not quite sure
exactly what he's looking at maybe his
new blade is making him see things the
next shot is of erendir also in a dark
forest but here he's protecting two
unknown cloaked figures behind him we'll
later see him picking up an arrow
mid-air and firing it back at the enemy
here we have a shot of what appears to
be a dar in front of a group of orcs you
can see has a pretty big scar on the top
right of his forehead but i can't be
sure if this is something he's had for a
long time or if aaron dear gave this to
him here are the harfoots with the
stranger pushing the cart in the back
man if i were him i'd just be using some
sort of magic elrond kelebrimbor king
gilgalad and prince during the fourth
toast with their goblets probably having
come to some form of agreement to build
this forge this looks to take place in
either oregon or linden nori offers an
apple to the stranger but look at the
completely destroyed crop in the
background i wonder if it's anywhere
near where they discover the beasts or
if these dead crops have something to do
with the orc invasion it looks like hal
brandt may get to forge after all in
numenor galadriel's wearing the same
outfit we see her in near the white tree
the ladrill talks to who i'm assuming is
the queen and or chancellor perhaps
they've come to a decision on what's to
happen to her but since we later see on
a boat with other soldiers she probably
gets her way speaking of which these
long white-haired warriors take on a
group of orcs who have taken over that
tavern in tehrad which we saw in
episodes one and two ayarian looks
pretty sullen as a crowd cheers behind
her maybe someone close to her is
leaving perhaps her brother or father
are off to fight in middle earth we'll
later see isildur in some sort of battle
check out the huge balls of flame in the
background there's also this shot of men
going off to war with the same color
flower petals on the ground now here's a
really cool shot of a ship in the new
bernard harbor exploding the blast seems
to be emanating from within the ship
itself so maybe it's some sort of
planned attack but just who it's meant
for is unknown and it looks as though we
will see a palantir as the queen uses it
to show galadriel the day they feared is
upon them bronwyn seems to team up with
erendir again at some point letting the
people know that together they can
survive this here we see the queen
holding on to something it looks like a
baby but in the books there's no mention
of her having a child so it's either
someone else's child or something else
entirely prince durin holds this crystal
i wonder if it's the object that was
glowing inside the chest we never got to
see in episode 2. galadrie and hal brand
venture off into battle this shot from
july's main teaser shows a crowd
cheering our farazan in front of a
building with murals of people building
in the wide shot you can see ayarian off
to the side not happy many of the people
here are holding scrolls perhaps plans
for buildings or whatnot but whatever it
is everyone seems to love it but her now
there are some shots that i didn't
include because i wasn't exactly sure
where they may fit in the timeline but
i'll absolutely get to those as we
continue on with the story these videos
have been a lot of fun to put together
and i hope you'll like and subscribe and
leave a comment with what you think will
happen next for more bad takes you can
follow me on twitter and instagram at
think story yt until next time remember
you've just earned your company
a water ration